[Musique]
je suis parti tout seul 387 que la même
somme et comment tu vas rentrer je sais
pas si ça s'appelle comment ta ville
déjà à l'ère du mois 7 à 11 ans m
et moi pas 3 et l'est où la terre des
ancêtres tubes mais c'est pas grave on
va trouver mais non c'est dit moi je te
jette à dakar demain soir j'ai un avion
[Musique]
bien oui je suis né et j'ai grandi à
trappes à côté oui de saint quentin en
yvelines
voilà même si désormais vous vivez à los
angeles on l'a vu à quelques instants
pour l'avant première le public
trappistes qui suit avec attention oui
oui j'en reviens je reviens souvent ici
à skywest avec mes films est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'avoir des salles
toujours bien pleines avec un public qui
moser d'un superbe accueil à chaque fois
et je suis très reconnaissant omar sy
jouer à domicile ce mardi soir l'enfant
de trappes de retour à saint quentin en
yvelines pour la présentation de son
nouveau film de l'autre côté du lit les
gens qui sont proches de moi valide le
film sont contents du film moi ça me
donne aussi la force et le encore plus
de force encore plus de courage pour le
défendre
le plus possible l'ancien trappistes
omar et son collègue du service
après-vente fred auront passé toute une
après-midi avec ces collégiens de
montfort l'amaury c'est la seconde fois
que les deux humoristes s'engage ainsi
pour l'association ela
c'est une fête c'est une fête une fête
qui est pas gratuite quoi c'est une fête
qui qui en plus de se placer une bonne
journée de rencontre et quelques enfants
ça permet aussi de récolter quelques
dons pour l'association ela donc ça fait
c'est double effet on ne fait jamais
assez
non est ce qu'il ya des bénévoles qui
sont là et qui le font toute l'année
nous le fait assez ponctuellement parce
que on est pris par le travail que voilà
on n'a pas forcément le temps tout le
temps donc déjà ça c'est un engagement
lourd et après il ya des événements à
ses concurrents elle comme comme
aujourd'hui
venir on le fait avec plaisir quoi il
chercher mon papier comment vous est
venue l'idée d'être l'assistait ça vous
gêne pas de vivre sur le dos des autres
ça va merci et vous pensez vous savez
quand même capable de travail j'en avais
d'humour j'aurais tellement que je suis
prêt à prendre les sabres séparez vous
tiendrais pas de ce métal comptant un
micro à moi omar sy qui vit à los
angeles qui vit aisément qui qui qui me
posent la question sur la banlieue
aujourd'hui j'ai quitté travail à 20 ans
c'est à moi que vous posez la question
il est déjà là le problème c'est que si
elle sert vraiment qu'on pose des
questions sur la banlieue on va jamais
le résoudre alesi est posée dans la
question les jeunes ils sont là bas ils
n'attendent que ça qu'on leur tende un
micro et qu'on leur donne la parole
c'est important de revenir à fait
réussis tu viens quand même leur
apporter un peu de ton expérience
ouais c'est important de placer pourtant
d'être là déjà pour eux c'est important
d'être là aussi
pour papy c'était surtout important pour
nous c'est important pour nous de
retenir et à côté nostalgique et un
petit peu
eh bien c'était l'avenir de voir tout ça
d
ressentir des trucs royal s'est passé
plein de choses qu'on nous c'est dans
cette salle donc de aussi il ya plein de
s'imbriquer plein de bonnes raisons de
revenir matin ce groupe travaille pas je
suis une femme c'est bon le sujet à ton
sujet alors là pour ce sujet
[Musique]